listen we had an umbrella for you but
you know what folks just step up for you
always and you know I have to say mama
put on a lip and A Lash and a dress
tonight mama got out of the house I know
honestly exactly you know not since
Alias we talked about this before that
you've held a television show do you
feel back at home on TV now you know
there's things I love about TV uniquely
I love the telling a story for longer
than just one block of time I love
watching it unfold and I love the
continuity I I'm so happy on set so I
just love to be with the crew for an
extended extended period of time and to
spend that much time with the cast
there's just a deepening of all of those
relationships do you ever think about
like the woman you were when Sydney was
on TV and the woman you are now and how
you compare those lives so different I
mean I I was I was a peanut I had a lot
to learn and yeah I do I'm grateful for
all of it you told me that you read this
book with Serafina right
I know that you said you think you're
kids think okay my mom's a little extra
but how proud really I know she has to
be proud and did you let her watch the
series what did she think my kids
haven't seen the series and I do think I
think they're I think they are proud I
think they are excited and they're ready
for me to be home like all right Mom
enough okay all right do your thing mom
then come home exactly you also told me
that you would love to share the screen
with Reese I have an idea who you could
play on the morning show yes because we
got to see her brother last he's right
but we've never seen like Jennifer
Aniston's sister and so I'm thinking why
don't you come and be her sister we need
the back story see
this is why you hire me as the
consultant absolutely this is a done
deal would you do something like that I
was I literally was thinking like who
could she be of course I would do I
would love to work with those ladies put
me in coach yeah she's ready to play I
love it um it's also been 20 years since
you first played Elektra on screen that
you're a superhero do you did you sit
those babies down and say listen y'all
need to know that mama is a superhero
you need to watch this and see this the
only one it mattered to is my youngest
and yes he's very well aware by the way
he was the cutest thing ever announcing
at the NBA All-Star Game favorite
YouTuber Jessa it was the cutest thing
ever he's a cute little guy thank you
having such a good time your birthday's
next week April 17th do you have big
plans do you think about are you like
I'm a stay at home and just chill I
honestly threw myself such a big party
for my 50th birthday that my 51st I feel
like it's a little more Low Pro I don't
really know what what we're gonna do I
know we're planting trees that's it
thank you
[Music]
foreign